Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is the way. The Mandalorian Season
3 isn't just about Grogu
Mando Bo Katan, the Darksaber.
We're in the middle
of a big rally for the Empire
and they've just revealed what Thrawn and
Moff Gideon's
Grand plans are, not just in season 3,
but in the larger sense,
going into future seasons
in all the other connected
shows like the Ahsoka series.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them
just starting with Thrawn and Moff
Gideon's plans during Season three.
Currently, Thrawn is still unseen.
There have only been Easter eggs
for him in Moff.
Gideon is still being held in a deep, dark
New Republic prison,
which Giancarlo Esposito called a gulag.
The recent episodes of The Mandalorian
had those former Imperials
joking about the official New
Republic cover story
they told everyone on the Galaxy News
that I heard
he escaped en route to the war tribunal.
No, that was just the cover story.
I heard they hooked
him up to a mind. Flayer.
They claim people believe Moff
Gideon had escaped en route
to the New Republic War Tribunal
after they captured him
in the Mandalorian Season
two episode 8.
When really, what happened is the New
Republic bypassed his war tribunal
and took him straight to the Star Wars
version of Guantanamo Bay,
where they been interrogating him
using similar mind flayer technology
we just saw Elia Kane using on Dr.
Pershing in the New Republic
has been trying to get all the information
that he has on the remnants of the Empire
of the forces that have been hiding
in the outer rim, the Empire secrets
or remnants of the Empire,
however you want to think about them.
They seemingly
don't know about Thrawn yet.
Ahsoka is the only person that we've seen
that actually realizes
that Thrawn has returned.
So The New Republic is currently torturing
Moff Gideon
just like he used to torture prisoners.
It's meant to be ironic
since he was about to do the same thing
to grow goo in season two.
Now he's the one in that position.
That's kind of why in the recent episodes
they wanted to make The New Republic
seem kind of shady too.
Like they were doing things
just as bad as the Empire used to do.
Giancarlo Esposito just revealed
we're supposed to get our first
look at Moff Gideon during season
three Episode five.
He didn't say what he'd be doing,
only that he wouldn't
actually appear on screen
until episode five.
But he's currently
rotting in a New Republic prison
waiting for his in Grand Admiral
Thrawn forces to break him out of prison.
That was the reason
why he was laughing at Mando Bo Katan
and the rest of them for
most of the season two finale, most of it
because he was a little surprised
at how quickly Luke
Skywalker sliced through his dark troopers
like they were hot butter.
The reason why he wasn't worried
when they attacked him like, Haha,
you think you caught me but you've done
nothing was because he and Grant Admiral
Thrawn had contingency plans for this
for the New Republic,
the Mandalorians just anything
that could threaten their grand plans.
So when they were attacking
Moff Gideon here, Mando, Luke Skywalker,
the others weren't
just dealing with Moff Gideon
and by defeating him
taking his cruiser here,
they didn't completely defeat
the remnants of the Empire.
This was just a small fraction
of their forces.
Because during that Ahsoka episode
in season two, we learned that Moff
Gideon had been working with Thrawn
for years,
whereas your master,
where is grand Admiral Thrawn?
Ahsoka asking Thorne's minion where he was
was meant to show that Thrawn
had been back in the regular galaxy,
hiding in the outer rim, working with Moff
Gideon the Seventh Fleet for years.
So Mando and the others
really only temporarily sidelined
a very small portion
of the Empire's forces.
This is one of the reasons
why you didn't see Moff
Gideon having his own star destroyer
during season two.
His ship was a much smaller
cruiser, way fewer tie fighters
and other ships as well.
A lot of people confused about that
at the time, too.
Like, isn't he supposed to be a moff?
Shouldn't he have a bigger capital ship
like a star destroyer and more forces?
Well, they do have more forces.
We just didn't see them during season two.
It's because their larger forces
rested with Thrawn and his seventh Fleet.
We saw a small portion,
a very small portion of that
during the Mandalorian season
three, Episode three
when the tie bombers,
the fuze squads of tie interceptors,
swarmed Bo Katan and Mando,
destroying her ancestral home on Cole
Abala all the big ships their real power,
the star destroyers,
the fleet of tie fighters.
That's Braun's Seventh Fleet.
And they've largely
kept those hidden up to now.
And it seems like only Ahsoka knows
they exist
because she's the only person So far
who's actually commented on Thrawn.
Everybody else.
The New Republic currently
is just thinking about Moff Gideon,
but he's only half of the equation
in right now.
Elissa Kane is acting as a double agent
for Thrawn on orders
to infiltrate the New Republic
by pretending she's a good citizen,
living up to the standards
of their amnesty program, pretending like
she's been rehabilitated by throwing Dr.
Pershing under the bus.
Like, would I really be working
for the Empire if I helped you
take down one of my former coworkers
as she eats that Imperial Biscuit?
Like, Oh, yeah, she's definitely evil.
The reason she did this, Dr.
Pershing, is to try and win her way
closer to where they're secretly holding
Moff Gideon
So The New Republic will trust her enough
to allow her to get closer
to where Moff Gideon is being held
so she can then break him out of prison
and they can return to Grand
Admiral Thrawn
and their larger forces in largely,
that's Moff Gideon and Grand Admiral
Thorne's plans during season three.
Just breaking moff Gideon out of prison,
then marshaling their forces,
the Seventh Fleet
and preparing for a larger strike
in the Mandalorian Season
four in the Ahsoka series.
The Ahsoka episodes will come
before the Mandalorian Season four,
so I'll explain how the Thrawn storyline
will continue during that during Ahsoka,
the story is more about Ahsoka physically
locating Thrawn, the Seventh Fleet,
Ezra Bridger and them having their first
actual confrontation on a smaller scale.
Ahsoka will be traveling with the crew
of the Ghost from Star Wars Rebels.
Pretty much
all the characters who are still alive
in this part of the timeline
are coming back from rebels in live action
like Sabine Wren, Ezra Bridger.
Mary Elizabeth
Winstead is playing a version of Hera.
They're also doing her son with Kanan,
who is for sensitive.
Maybe he'll begin training in the force
too, like Raghu has started training again
in the force.
They're also doing a live action
version of Chopper.
We'll get a tease for Thrawn
in the Seventh Fleet
during the Mandalorian Season
three by the end of the season.
But there'll be a larger battle where
we'll see them on screen in some way,
but we'll see them in a much bigger way
during the Ahsoka series.
The pacing is kind of like what we saw
during the Mandalorian season
one and season two with Moff Gideon,
where we really only saw him
at the end of The Mandalorian season one.
Then he became a much bigger character
during season two.
That's kind of how they're treating
the Thrawn character,
where we learn about him
during season three,
but he becomes a much bigger character
in future seasons after that.
In a larger sense, like talking
about all the seasons of The Mandalorian,
however long it runs all these connected
shows Thrawn and Moff Gideon's
grand plans are meant to be an adaptation
of the heir to the Empire
Thrawn storyline, with a few characters
swapped in and a few minor story changes.
Like during that storyline,
they had a Jedi cloning plot,
but it was a Luke Skywalker clone
in a clone.
Jedi Master
George Cobos on the Mandalorian Grogu
who is getting that storyline?
I don't think they're building up to Grogu
fighting an evil clone of Grogu who?
Doctor Pershing's whole speech
about combining the attributes
of different genomes to create
superior clones
was then revealing Thrawn and Moff
Gideon wanted to create a force sensitive,
ultra powerful clone troopers
that they can control like finger puppets,
mostly because clones were easier
to control than regular stormtroopers.
We're seeing a version of that play out
on the bad batch episodes with the Mount
Tanto storyline, which is also from
the heir to the Empire Thrawn storyline.
Like I said,
they're adapting the heir to the Empire
trilogy, just doing it in live action
and through the animated series.
The animated series
are also meant to be canon.
If that wasn't clear,
there's a little bit confusion about that
because a lot of people
only watch the live action
Star Wars series.
But Dave Filoni does the animated series.
All those are meant to be canon.
So that's why
when the animated characters
from those series show up in live action,
all of their backstory, these are the same
as they were during the animated series.
But this is the other reason why
the Empire Moff, Gideon and Thrawn wanted
all of the Mandalorians Beskar
where they took Mandalore to begin with
because they want to use the best scar
to upgrade
all these advanced clone Troopers armor.
It would make their army nearly invincible
in this part of the timeline
in army of force sensitive clones
in nearly indestructible armor.
But even with all their modern cloning
technology and advancements
that they've been teasing on the bad batch
since the prequels
growing,
all those new clones would take years.
Which is
why Thrawn has been biding his time,
hiding in the outer rim this whole time.
Currently,
while he's trying to break Moff Gideon
out of prison with Elia Kane's
help, he's
also trying to prevent any other forces
that could challenge him.
While
this is all playing out in the background,
which is why he was just trying
to kill Bo Katan in Mando.
Now he was mostly trying to kill Bo Katan
there.
He only cares about Mando
because he has Grogu
who like he really cares about Grogu
who they want to get him back
so they can continue their cloning
experiments.
The reason why Thrawn tried to kill
Bo Katan is because he believes she's
one of the few people
that actually has a chance
at uniting the Mandalorian factions in it.
The Mandalorian clans were able to unite.
They be able to challenge
Thrawn seventh Fleet.
That's why he wants to stop that before
the Mandalorians can come together.
He wants to keep them all
fighting each other
so they're too busy to fight him.
He also doesn't want them to retake
Mandalore and gain control
of the best of our minds.
Again, that's one of the reasons why
Mandalore was so important to the Empire
and now to Thrawn and present day
in why they executed the Great Purge
because the Mandalorians
wouldn't capitulate to the Emperor
and give him access to all their weapons,
technology and beskar.
So this is why The Mandalorian Season
three
has been all about the different factions
coming together on their side of things.
We'll probably see a bigger teaser
for that at the end of the season.
That's what the entire mythos
or plot is leading up to.
Bo Katan
eventually revealing the living mythos
to all the different Mandalorian factions.
So they all believe the way that
she started to become a believer again.
The myth is or isn't just meant to be
a symbol of Boka Han's redemption.
It's meant to be a symbol
for the redemption of all mandalorians
all these different groups.
That's why the Armor told Bo Katan
that the myth is or belonged
to all Mandalorians.
It was a symbol of all mandalorians.
So the early theory is that all these
Mandalorian factions will see the myth
they or by the end of the season,
and it'll be one of those huge
rally moments where they all cry out
for Mandalore and go out on a high note,
but also at the same time
Thrawn and Moff, Gideon
doing the same thing on their side.
They also rally in a huge escalation
on both sides,
pushing into the Ahsoka episodes
in The Mandalorian Season four.
So even though we're in Season
three, Jon Favreau has teased that
this story will continue for many seasons,
like The Mandalorian
will continue for a long time,
all these other spinoff shows,
which is why it seems like
things are moving along so slowly.
My Full Mandalorian Season
three Episode five Video
will post this week after they release it.
I've got a couple other
bonus videos I'm working on.
If you have any other questions about
what's going on with Thrawn Moff Gideon,
Other characters like Grogu to his force
training just right then below
in the comments, everyone click here for
that Season three Episode five Video Link.
As soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
This is the way.